[Music]
good evening everybody all
members officers and
no there are no members of the public
that i can see but for the purposes of
the recording
and welcome to any members of the public
who are joining us on the
livestream facility welcome to today's
meeting
of the overview and scrutiny panel today
is of course the 8th of july
2021. if i just run through
the housekeeping procedures if the fire
alarm is activated please vacate the
offices
down the main staircase opposite the
lifts in the foyer
and assemble at hawley square on the
green officers will assist you and
advise you when it's deemed safe to
return to the chamber
with everyone present please ensure
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and they are not used to make or receive
phone calls whilst the meeting
is in progress please note
that this meeting is being live stream
for members of the public
and it will also be recorded and will
subsequently be broadcast
on the internet is there anyone here who
intends to film
the proceedings
for the benefit of the members of the
public who may not be able to see at
this point
the answer is no
speaking under rule 20.1 i've not
received
any request to speak under rule 20.1 but
are there any
members in the room who would like to
speak
okay thank you and public speaking i've
not received any requests
for public speaking there being no
members of the public presence
the answer for that is also no
so just before i move to the election of
the check and i might only be here for a
few minutes
um i would like to thank councillor bob
bayford
for the excellent work he did that i was
aware of in watching him
when i attended these meetings and the
calm and
collected manner in which he conducted
them
uh and the preparation that together
with yourselves he was able to make for
the work program
um so uh thanks to him
for that the first substantive item then
is the election
of a chair are there any nominations
please
yes council king i'd like to nominate
alan curry
thank you are there any more nominations
councillor piper thank you i'd like to
nominate councillor stuart piper
[Music]
can we have seconders for each of those
proposals please
which one are you seconding please
council fellas
thank you
thank you very much councilman
thank you members are there anymore it's
apparent that obviously my name is one
of them so at this point i have to
vacate
the chair that i sit and just in case
there's any
uh misunderstanding as to why
although i am only the vice chairman of
this committee at the moment the chair
that i'm operating from
is the chair of the chair of this
committee so i do have to leave
the room whilst i hand over to
nick hughes to take over the proceedings
uh thank you councillor poper um so
what we'll do now uh in order to ensure
that the
uh election of the actual chairman or
the vote
has a counselor who has a casting vote
what we'll do is we'll
run a election of
a temporary chairman to oversee the
election of chairman if that makes sense
to members
so can i have a proposal for a temporary
chair please
no you are okay to stay because you're
not presiding
in the election of the chairman so
that's okay that's fine
council of fellows
okay is there a seconder for that uh
councillor tomlinson are there any other
nominations to
be the temporary chairman
nope okay so counselor piper
is now in the
be already chair
[Music]
good evening everybody thank you for the
opportunity of doing this we have two
candidates
uh councillor alan curry and councillor
stuart piper
well those in favor of councillor stuart
piper being the chairman
of this committee will you please raise
your hands
thank you very much and uh those who
would like
councillor alan curry to be the chairman
would you please raise your hands
are there any abstentions oh
counselor
thank you very much councillors it was
um eight to four in favor of council
stuart piper who will now be the
chairman of the overview and scrutiny
panel
thank you very much
i've thank you very much i will try
to do it as well as i mentioned
councillor baker
did by giving everybody the opportunity
to speak
as often as is necessary for the item
that's being discussed
to be thoroughly discussed katsuki
[Music]
thank you very much
now i'm just going to turn to you and
say is that happening today
yes
the leader of the council chooses the
sorry so because the vice chairman see
or vice german's position has been
vacated
that's a casual vacancy which is always
done at the panel
rather than at full council which is
done only annual council
so um there is there is the opportunity
if members want to
appoint a vice chairman at this meeting
or it can roll forward to the
next um ordinary well the next scrutiny
meeting which is
uh 20th of july isn't it yeah on the
20th of july
so it's up to uh up to the panels to
decide we can either do it tonight
or on the 20th
microphone members i'm quite happy to go
with the election this evening if you'd
like to
are there any other nominations for vice
chair
i'm sorry i didn't hear you cancer
council of fellows our second lecturer
nominated by
councillor moore thank you
councillor paul moore
yes i've got councillor king nominated
councillor curry
and seconded by
thank you
and the second of four
council fellows please thank you
let's cancel comical thank you very much
in the order in which the nominations
came to me then i think is the fairest
way to do it can i have
a show of hands visa all those in favor
of
the vice chairman or chairperson being
councillor curry all those in favor
please
and all those in favor of
council of fellows please okay
thank you very much councillor fellows
and is then appointed as the vice chair
of this committee thank you very much
thank you very much for that then uh
moving on with the agenda the apologies
for absence i've received apologies from
the following members councillor huxley
substituted by councillor whitehead and
councillor scott
substituted by councillor right and as
you are
now aware council of fellows is with
this committee replacing
councillor bayford are there any more
apologies i think everyone else is here
thank you very much next item is
decorations of interest are there any
declarations of interest to be made
thank you very much
substantive agenda item number four then
is the proposed disposal of 18
albert street the call-in of this
previously made cabinet decision so i
will now ask
bob porter to please introduce the
report
thank you councillor piper uh good
evening um i'm not going to say very
much
by way of introduction um other than um
to say that the report that was
considered by cabinet
on the 17th of june is attached to the
report that you see this evening
and just a little bit in terms of the
background
the property in albert street um is
owned by the council and that and it's
held in the council's
housing revenue account and that account
is ring fenced
for the purposes of providing housing
for residents in the district um and
there are rules about the way that
assets held in within the housing
revenue account they are used and funded
um when that property uh it was it was
shared ownership
uh property when it became vacant um we
negotiated to purchase back the share
um so that um the situation could be
resolved it's a property in very poor
condition
and the previous shared ownership owners
were unable to undertake the work
um following that we then
looked at the various options for that
property
including bringing it back into use as
affordable housing which
say is the main purpose of the housing
revenue account
for a number of reasons we concluded
that wasn't appropriate
partly because of the cost and partly
because of the
the poor layout inside the building it's
the accommodations spread over three
floors
there's a very narrow steep and winding
staircase
there's no outside immunity space so
that it wouldn't really make a suitable
home for family accommodation so for
those two reasons
we concluded it wasn't suitable for
retention in the housing revenue account
for the provision of affordable housing
and that led to the recommendations for
uh
for disposal um obviously myself
uh and uh councillor joel bayford
academy member for housing are here this
evening if you have any questions
um we'd be happy to try and answer them
thank you
thank you very much mr supporter um
council bayford thank you very much for
coming
um is there anything you would like to
add
at this point thank you chair um it's
just that the the um
question seems to focus on why um this
property wasn't included in the
um ramsgate bid um i i'm unable to say
why it wasn't
because it wasn't this administration
that decided that
um however the as bob said the
um it's an hr hra property
and as far as i can see there would be
no reason to consider it for anything
other than to raise money to put back
into the hr
a fund and support housing for rent
which is desperately needed
its condition and the potential costs of
renovation have already been discussed
so i'm satisfied that its sale is the
most economic option
and that due process has been followed
thank you
very much councillor bayford uh members
of the panel
uh do you have any comments that you'd
like to make
thank you thank you chair um
this is a um a property that is in an up
and coming area of ramsgate yes it's in
a dreadful state
but it is a historic asset and ramsgate
members are very concerned at the loss
of historic assets from the council's uh
uh asset register we really wanted to
check that all
options had been considered and this was
not looking at the previous leveling up
fund bid
but looking at other potential bids as
part of the ramsgate future program that
the regeneration team are looking at at
the moment
to see whether which is specifically
about
ramsgate's historic assets we have a
heritage action zone
we have a close relationship with
historic england and other likely
funders
uh we've got um this ramsgate future
program
which is looking at specifically at this
type of asset
it's difficult to find any evidence that
um
that cabinet has considered anything
other than housing options and we quite
see that housing is is not a
suitable option uh for for this property
and that it would need far too much
renovation in any event
for that but we do consider that there
are other possibilities
for this building um we've had a paper
produced by trainee architect that i
know council baker and
mr porter have seen um looking at the
possibility that it might be
a community asset a cafe a gallery
airbnb
community space if it could if we could
get grant funding
to restore it the training organization
the liberty group across the road
is very interested in collaborating with
the council on developing the building
uh with the with a view to the young
people that they train
being trained in heritage asset
renovation
which is something that historic england
is extremely keen on pushing at the
moment
that's the kind of project that would
appeal massively
to external funders it's exactly the
kind of thing it would give
training and potential and a feeling of
ownership
to those young people and it would be a
community project
that would uh develop those skills and
training
in precisely the way that the leveling
up fund is trying to do
to develop potential of young people in
our area those are just two
possibilities
now we do know that the housing revenue
account is at rings vented account and
that
it has specific rules that uh concern it
that's why i proposed under 24.1 at the
cabinet meeting
that we could do the cabinet considered
delaying this
for a period of three months so that we
could
explore with the regeneration team
whether there were any possibilities for
bringing in
external funding to put into the housing
revenue account
um to compensate the account for the
loss of this building
and to develop it in other directions
um but that was not uh considered i'm a
new counselor i was a bit dismayed to be
honest to discover that the processor
cabinet
is you speak and then you know that's it
there isn't a discussion i hadn't
realized that
um and that um councillor baker had her
response
uh ready for whatever it was i'd said so
if i'd said i think we should burn down
the building and claim on the insurance
the response felt like it would be the
same um
and that felt to me like perhaps we
weren't considering all the options as
widely as we might
and that it perhaps behold the council
to to think again
about what the options might be for this
beautiful but very very badly neglected
building
thank you
thank you very much chair um i'm happy
to chip in
in relation to the leveling up bid
um as that's what the question
originally focused on
and so if everyone that's
i don't know who has the laptops open
but um top page six
so in terms of it going forwards as part
of the leveling up
vid as i quite directly there's no
approved budget in the general capital
program to facilitate this purchase
because it would be it would have to be
bought by the general fund in order to
enable that
um moreover it should also be noted that
the leveling up bid was approved on the
provision that there would not be a cash
contribution from the authority
nor an expectation the council would be
underwriting any financial contributions
referenced by 10 match
in the government's narrative that are
required from the private sector
and so in brief answer
the money wasn't allocated in order to
purchase it and the terms of leveling up
fund meant that it couldn't
be included in that way um
for me the primary focus was what the
hra is
and the hra is there to provide housing
and we have to look at how we provide
the best value
for money in order to do that in order
to purchase as many properties as
possible
and in order to renovate this if we were
doing it
on our own we would effectively run into
negative in terms of providing
accommodation and that would be a
significant struggle for us
so that's why it was considered in that
sense in terms of the leveling up front
thank you thank you very much councillor
whitehead uh
council king peace thank you chair
um i can quite understand that it
couldn't be
part of the leveling up fund and i agree
that you know obviously this is already
ring fence money so we've got to look at
it for housing
but what would be the harm in delaying
for three months to look at other
sources of funding for some of the ideas
that
councillor austin has suggested
thank you i think i saw another hand did
i see a little handle
cancer paul moore please thank you sir
um
i i'm in favor of uh
paul porter's recommendation to get rid
of this property
i'm also in allegiance with councillor
whitehead
in what she was talking about and
leveling up and that sort of thing
this property is dilapidated we don't
have the funds for it
delaying it will only mean that we won't
have the money coming in for the hra
which we need
this was already discussed and proposed
in previous meetings
and was passed by the previous people in
charge
and i think by delaying will not benefit
anyone
other than just getting the property in
the worst state and we'll get less money
for it
so i think she'll just get rid of it
thank you
thank you councilman
any other members uh you can come back
yes come on yeah just i just wanted to
clarify a couple of things first of all
i wasn't suggesting you should have been
part of the learning
fund because that was a geographically
specific bid and and it's outside the
area
but it does have potential to be part of
the landscape future
program which is looking at historic
buildings
and yes there is the issue about that it
might decline further but on the other
hand
frankly the way that property values in
that area of ramsgate are increasing
i think that will be more than balanced
uh over three months
by the uh um by the the
increase in property value generally so
i would refer you back to councillor
king's question what harm would there be
in delaying simply for three months
thank you
thank you i'm happy to take guidance
from uh mr hughes at the moment
um if necessary but um
my understanding is that any calling
needs to be specifically related to
the procedure that the
cabinet has followed and
i'm struggling to find out whether a
delay
fits the procedure the delay was the
proposal to respond to the fact that the
procedure we felt hadn't been followed
because the full range of options hadn't
been considered
thank you members i'll just wait for an
advice
so the answer that i've received is yes
it is a viable
option that you could make as a
a recommendation if you wish in just a
few moments but i'd like to go back to
mr porter please first to see if there's
anything else that he would like to add
thank you councillor piper um well
there's the question about um
the delay would there be any negative
implications to delay and
the advice i gave to cabinet at the
meeting um was that the property is in
very poor condition and delay would see
it deteriorate further so
you know i shared that information at
the time and i think my recommendation
would be
um not to delay but to make an early
decision about what to do with the
property so that further deterioration
could be avoided
thank you
thank you mr porter
um i wonder whether it would be possible
bob could you uh
possibly say you know the likelihood or
the possibility of being able to explore
additional funding to to compensate the
hra
i don't know whether that's possible
because we
we we've said and you said in your
report that if you wanted to do
something with this building other than
what you're proposing
we would have to get the general fund to
buy it from the hra
so i think what council austin is
suggesting is that instead of doing that
or
you know to to compensate in some way we
get the extent
of the external funding whatever that
might be to compensate the hra but i
don't know whether that's possible
and i don't know whether you can comment
on that
i'm not sure i'm really the right person
to comment on that either really to be
honest um
i understand the workings of the housing
revenue account and what resources are
available but
um i i can say it wasn't in the original
reports cabinet but i can say in the
build up to preparing the report
i had discussions with the director of
regeneration about
whether there were alternative options
and the view was that actually
there weren't likely sources of funding
for for that property so um
my you know clearly um the budget
implications
are uh in this report because they were
drafted by
uh the the deputy 151 officer in
preparing this report for the panel
um and it would be a matter for full
council
about whether they wanted to allocate
allocate any funding
um to transfer this from the hra into
the general fund
um i i can't really answer about how
realistic that prospect is i'm afraid
thank you
a question from the chairperson i'm
gonna try not to ask too many questions
uh at these meetings but um
if there is local interest
in acquiring this building to make good
use of it
it seems to me that to acquire the
building
now or at least as soon as possible
would be a good idea given its likely
increase in value
is there any way in which
that local interest could in fact
bid at the auction to buy it
or is it the case that they would need
to have uh
hoped for funding from other agencies in
place
already i'm sorry i don't know the
answer to that question
um i think this is something that uh
council bathroom suggested actually um
in response to the architect who wrote
in with some ideas that that he go ahead
and purchase it himself
the difficulty with that is that the
amount that we would need
to refurbish the building is substantial
we would have to go for grant funding
for that
i'd say a combination for example of the
training organization and the council
would be in a really strong position to
get that grant funding
um and private individuals simply
wouldn't
thank you very much
any more comments from members please
uh thank you chair and well done for
taking the chair um
i have read the report uh bob's
reporting is always
excellent and given us the guidance
which um
you know we're talking about tonight um
totally understand
um councillor austin's views about
shall we say the community taking on
board
um a property like this i mean
i know of the property i haven't seen it
recently but i know of it
and yes it is sad to see our lovely old
buildings deteriorate
my concern about if it went to community
and we see it so often
um when most of us have been involved in
community things projects or whatever
they they can be taken over but all the
best will in the world
um by whoever
and then they run out of money and
i feel quite strongly about this having
seen
i always say with this part of the world
in market certain organizations this has
happened to
say they mean well they take on it might
be a council property
and then the next thing you find they're
crying out for funds
because it hasn't sadly worked
so my own feeling i think we should go
with
the um what the officers and mr porter's
recommendation is
to put it out fortune thank you chair
thank you very much
the proposal was that the council
retained
ownership of the building not that it
went to a community organization
but that obviously is something that
would need to be discussed
thank you very much we can come to that
in just a second when
uh if there are no more comments that
members would like to make
it seems to me that we have two
ideas that have been suggested which
would need to form a proposal
one is coming from yourself i think
council russian in just a minute
and then one i believe from yourself
councillor moore
only into agreeing with what yeah has
been propositioned yes
those those are the two options that we
have before us
to take no further action and or
to refer it back to cabinet setting out
the recommendations
from this panel so to do that we will
need
a proposal which will require a proposal
a seconder and a vote
so my proposal would be to delay the
sale for three months to enable
discussion with the director of
regeneration and
uh potential funders who might be
willing to contribute to
to the refurbishment of the building as
part of the
ramsgate future program thank you
council austin i
hope charles is able to write faster
than me
i got most of it that is a proposal then
from council austrian thank you very
much do we have a seconder for that
proposal
councillor king thank you very much
there any other proposals from the floor
council paul moore please only mind
sharing which is to take no further
action
and do we have a second before that
please
council thomason i've seen your hand
thank you
okay uh the proposal made by councillor
austin
proposed and seconded by council keen
can we have a show of hands for those
in favor of that proposal please
thank you the proposal from councillor
paul moore that we take no further
action which confirms the decision
the council has made can we have a show
of hands in favor of that proposal
please
are there any abstentions
i should make it clear is this for the
first proposal the second
or because i didn't ask for the first
proposal
any abstentions two
three thank you very much
so it's the decision
so the decision members thank you for
the discussion is that
this panel takes no further action and
therefore the
cabinet decision is confirmed thank you
very much
for all your comments that concludes the
business for tonight's meeting
i now declare this meeting close
according to that clock
at 1933
could i thank everyone for their time
and apologize for bringing you out on
yet another evening
thank you
[Music]
you